now we've been moving in and out of
restrictions all of this year
there have been hope that they would be
relaxed a bit for christmas but of
course the hope was dashed
yesterday we can talk now to the global
chair of public health at edinburgh
university professor debbie
schroeder thank you very much for being
on the programme this morning
on the 25th of november you tweeted to
say
we will pay for our christmas holidays
with january and february lockdowns
just because you can do something
doesn't necessarily mean you
should so was the government wrong to
allow christmas
mixing in the first place well i think
they were in an impossible situation
um you know you're stuck between what
people want to hear what they want to do
fatigue as well as what we know
scientifically we need to do to suppress
this virus and unfortunately with the
emergence of this
new strain as well as rising prevalence
they were forced into these restrictions
as long as this virus is circulating it
is too risky to allow travel across the
country as well as indoor mixing
we already know what will happen we've
seen it over the past couple months
how concerned should we be about this
new variant
of the virus and matt hancock saying
that it's up to 70
more transmissible what does that mean
for the things that we do to try and
keep ourselves safe
face masks social distancing are they
all going to be less effective
well i think there's three pieces of
information scientists are looking for
the first
is it more infectious is it doubling
time faster and it seems like it is and
this is what's really concerning because
it's going to become harder to suppress
it with our existing tier system
the second is are the health outcomes
more severe do we see more
hospitalizations
and we just don't know that yet and the
third is could it evade our vaccines
if it actually changes quite
significantly and so we don't know that
either it seems like the vaccines are
still effective
but this just also shows why suppression
is important the more virus that is
circulating
the more chances there are to have
different mutations as well as jumps
into different animals across species
and back into humans
and then it's harder for us to keep a
handle on the situation
this feels to be quite important because
it seems to me like the government is
trying to reassure people that actually
the new variant
doesn't cause increased mortality that
there's no reason to think it could
react differently to the virus
but you're saying that it's too early to
know those two things
yeah i would say it's too early to say
right now i mean obviously they were
concerned enough not all the information
is yet public
to want to go into quite harsh
restrictions quite quickly
and if we look at scotland i mean
scotland already was running
a lower infection rate but to go into
quite a harsh lockdown over the holiday
period to extend the school holidays
to really try to get those numbers low i
mean i think i would hope the rest of
the uk would follow that model which is
we got to really crunch this we've got
to kind of
eliminate as much as possible to the
lowest level this virus
because that's how we'll reopen our
economy and that's the lesson from east
asia from the pacific countries
from norway from finland the countries
that are keeping a lid on this are doing
it by keeping their numbers
really low through you know clear public
health guidance and measures
let's talk about schools and i've seen
quite a lot of rumors on twitter that
this new variant has an increased
transmission among
children is that true as far as you're
aware
and should we be thinking about closing
schools
well um i haven't seen the evidence
behind that i know it has they're having
rumors swirling
which is not helpful we actually need to
have data but i think this was probably
during by seeing
in the ons surveys how many children and
the growing number of infections in
kind of children age groups especially
age 12 to 18 and but moving down into
younger age groups
which we hadn't seen a couple months ago
schools are really tricky i think we
need to divide kids
under 12 which we know generally have
not transmitted that well between each
other
we haven't seen many outbreaks in
nurseries and primary schools and
secondary schools where children are
very much like adults after age 12 and
how we manage those
but schools need to be kept open as much
as possible and the way to do that is to
keep our community prevalence low so
viruses never even enter the school in
the first place
i'm talking about keeping the virus
prevalence low of course the tier system
tier three was unable to really
constrain the spread of the virus at the
new variant of the virus
in kent with that in mind should people
in tier 4
be preparing for the long haul are we
effectively going to be staying in
tier 4 until the vaccine's rolled out
yeah i mean i think right now we just
need a broader strategy of what to do
with this virus and the more that we've
seen about it we've seen we have to
pivot away from a flu model which is
accepting this as a seasonal infection
which is endemic towards more of a sars
model where we really just try to keep
the numbers as low as possible and use
testing vaccines treatments to keep a
handle on it and try to keep our economy
and society going
i think trying to keep kind of low level
restrictions for a long period of time
is not going to work with this virus
it's too infectious
looks like it's becoming more infectious
and the associated hospitalization rate
and it's also younger people one of the
astonishing things looking at the united
states is in july the excess mortality
in the age group 25 to 44
was considerably higher because of covet
19. so it's not like
this only affects older people over the
age of 80. this can actually hit younger
people too and so this is why
when people see these restrictions and
think wow they're really harsh this is
why they're being introduced because
this is a serious problem
um it's all pretty gloomy let's try and
end on a bit of hope
vaccine matt hancock was saying that 350
000 people
have received it that the rate people
getting the vaccine
is increasing as well at what point do
you think we
may have vaccinated enough vulnerable
people to start relaxing the
restrictions
well the unknown about the vaccine is
whether it can stop transmission so
whether someone stops being infectious
or whether it just stops severe
coca-19 we know it's stopped severe
covered 19 we know they're safe
but it's the transmission element that
we're missing that could help us really
start to release restrictions and
develop a strategy for who to vaccinate
but this is the message of hope i would
give to people we are only
you know less than a year into this
pandemic new virus
we have sequenced it we have pcr testing
we have rapid testing we have mass
testing we have antibody testing
we have treatments which means if
someone is admitted to hospital you're
much more likely to survive
doctors know how to handle patients
better clinically and we have three at
least
three effective and safe vaccines with
pfizer moderna and astrazeneca
and so looking ahead in the uk we are so
privileged to live in a rich country
a wealthy country that can access these
vaccines that can do the testing can do
the therapeutics
to have the nhs because we will be in a
good position this spring by march next
summer
things are going to look much brighter
and what we're going to have to worry
about then is the poorer countries who
don't have those resources and will be
left behind
okay thank you so much for being on the
program i'm always good to talk debbie
schroder there